i can't recognize you  you look amazing  is that a that's a sword  [Music]  [Music]  would you like to come chat about it yes  sir  do you feel ever bit amazing in this  yeah i actually i think it's my favorite  look ever i feel sick what inspired this  look um it's kind of inspired by the  movie dune which uh  isn't it's an american film americans  worked on it so it's sort of hits the  game  i'm seeing your incredible design  tonight then  how long did it take to get you into  this number tonight only a couple of  hours  like two minutes to get into the dress  this is made out of them from rusted  guns oh my god  you know  that's it we can make america gun free  but florida  you're on security detail tonight  [Music]  you